ladies and gentlemen today is an
important day in the coffee zilla army
history today is the day we start a
brand new series i should have started
this a long time ago
honestly scams are bigger than ever and
one of the scams that we have
really not covered on this show but is
going to be a regular piece now
our ppp loan scams aka covet relief
and i think we can all agree in a time
where people
are more desperate than ever where
people are losing their jobs
it's important for ppp loans things that
are intended to help people who are
struggling
are used appropriately and not taken
up by people who are scamming the system
so we're going to cover it
i'm calling it the ppp chronicles
uh please you could put it on thank you
[Music]
something like the lie about the size of
the peppers and they will be cut
or they will be god and if you have a
small ppp that is okay
but you must not lie to the government
not the government
maybe a new girlfriend
welcome to the beep beep beep
chronicles uh we could give you hundreds
of clips just like that we have them
uh we didn't want this to go on too long
welcome one and all to the ppp
chronicles today of course we're talking
about david hines a man who got
four million dollars in ppp money from
the government
and spent it partly on a lamborghini
you heard that right he got four million
dollars now to be clear
how you get this money is you have to
submit an application
and in that application you have to say
all the employees you're going to save
because now you have this loan and all
this money so
what david hines did is he fabricated
his employees
and he fabricated employment expenses of
four million dollars a month not to
mention he was saying
he was spending that on 70 people now
i'm no rockefeller but that math doesn't
really add up
if you're spending 4 million dollars
monthly on 70 people that means you're
spending an average of 50
000 per employee per month you're paying
them what seven hundred thousand dollars
a year
no it's completely ridiculous from the
start and yet
he got the money he got that four
million dollars from
several of these ppp loan requests
and of course now the feds have found
out but not before he spent a good 400
of that money 300 000 of it being on a
lamborghini huracan
but then there's a bunch of smaller
expenses like here he has uh
on the 13th of may he sent fifteen
thousand dollars
to mom ninety five hundred dollars to
heinz cash fifteen thousand dollars to
mom
we have miami beach hotel stays we've
got a diamond store he went to another
miami beach store
look he's just going on a gigantic
spinning spree this guy and i
you know frankly i don't blame him he's
got all this free money from the
government but let me say
i think the government should have known
that heinz would have committed this
kind of fraud because douchebags leave
signs that's what i always say it's my
saying i've said it all a lot
i just made it up but i stand by it here
today guys people don't just
go out and take four million dollars
from the government with fraud
they leave clues before they do that how
could we have possibly known
david hines would have done a thing like
this are there clues
are there things in the past that maybe
we should have realized that this guy
is a douchebag he said sarcastically
setting up the next clip
now at 5 30 a man cbs 4 news first met
last week when he was busted by miami
police for not wearing a mask
is now in much bigger trouble with the
law yes david hines is someone who
refuses to wear a mask
he doesn't know if he can bring himself
to wearing a mask i think
it's uh hilarious
it's so ridiculous i i don't know i like
to bring myself to actually
participate in this insanity i feel
silly you know
after all it's not like miami's
basically on fire with covet patients
right now and it's not like that's where
he lives
but actually it gets worse because this
man
who at the time of this local news
segment had taken four million dollars
from the government
also thought it would be wise to speak
out about the unfairness of the ppp
program the government the treasury they
gave two trillion dollars for ppp loans
for small businesses
85 of it went to major corporations
every small business i know of
uh they're shutting their doors can't
pay the rent here's this guy
saying that oh the government's you know
he's they're giving the money to
all the wrong people yeah i guess you're
a good person to say that huh
he's saying all these small businesses
are going out of business no no
apparently you're not apparently the
program's working just fine you got four
million dollars from it
maybe small businesses around your town
are going out of business because
they're not
forging documents like you are so at
this point he's set for his trial in
october
and in the meantime he's out on bond for
a hundred thousand dollars
gee i wonder where he got that money
from and he's currently living with his
mother
hopefully his mom is taking good care of
him since he gave her thirty thousand
dollars
uh so that really paid off for him but i
hope that he gets
a very serious sentence here and then it
sends a message
that hey your government can steal from
you but you better never steal from your
[Music]
government
comes along